welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the
Mandalorian season 3 episode 1 chapter
17 the apostate from Pergo hyperspace
whales to creepy culty baptisms with
Jimmy Kimmel's nephew dank ferric it
feels good to be back and Dave filoni
Star Wars and yes I look and sound
different right now because I'm shooting
this in the new Rockstar's Burbank
office but in future weeks I'll be back
in my little hole hey by the way you can
watch my behind the scenes initial
research process for this breakdown in
yesterday's live stream on the Deep dive
Channel and Tommy and I tackled all the
big questions in our Wikileaks after
show I love talking Star Wars with that
guy but here right here let's break down
all the Easter eggs references and
visual details they might have missed
because yes we do have some translations
of alien languages and the best way to
support our network is to grab one of
our Mando inspired shirts at nerd
riot.shop okay the opening lucasfilm
Fanfare as usual shows a series of
droids and metallic helmets with the
glow of red and blue lightsabers waving
over them we see Darth Vader R2D2 and
then the helmet of Finnick sand and
Imperial pilot bocaton's helmet ig-11 a
Speeder Bike Stormtrooper the armorer
and then Den interesting that we paired
the armorer with Den jarin I believe
that the armorer may be the villain of
this season but overall this we hear
some hammering the sounds of the armor
working the forge in a cave this of
course is a favorite hephestian
archetype of John Favreau from his first
Iron Man film and the sounds of
hammering played over the credits of
Tony Stark's last MCU movie Avengers end
game
but here in Star Wars it starkly reminds
us that this series is at its core the
story of the Mandalorian people and the
cultist Creed of the watch it's as much
about Hammers and helmets as it is about
Sabers and starfighters and the imagery
of this opening scene is shot like a
sacred religious ceremony filled with
symbolism and Magic now if you first
thought that we were actually watching a
flashback to den jarin's baptism that
may have actually been by Design the
actor they picked does vaguely look
similar to the young actor they used for
young din it speaks to the cyclical
timelessness of these Mandalorian
rituals by Saving these people adult and
jarion is saving his past self he is
intervening in Nature's cruel attempt to
stymie the watch's succession the armor
reports in this tempering liquid to cast
the best scar and it causes a turquoise
Shimmer in the water giving some
mysticism to this Clan's ritual it's
like the anointing with oil in a
Christian Sacrament a sign of higher
power at work Favreau did confirm that
to contrast the Eastern philosophical
underpinnings of the Jedi code for the
mandalorians they pulled from a variety
of religions including Western Warrior
codes like those of the Romans and the
Romans were warriors who were overtaken
by a fanatical religious faction within
Rome a little cult called Christianity
hey everyone I'm a baptized Catholic I'm
just I'm spoken some fun but also you
know what's the difference between a
religion and a cult a couple hundred
years in IRS taxes and Status okay the
mythosar is framed in the background
with 10 flame Jets of the forge as if
this mythosar itself is being roasted in
a ceremonial pyre the 10 Jets may also
reflect the 10 red Petals on the branch
of the house visual sigil as the armorer
Hammers away this mythosar watches from
the background overseeing everything
like a crucifix hanging on the wall in
the background of a church living
yorensen's collaborator Joseph Shirley
returns to do the music for this season
after doing the music for the book of
Boba Fett and his percussion beats
intensely matching the hammering the
armorer paints this child's best scar
helmet blue the color coding seems to
adhere to each Clan within the watch and
as we see with Paz visla the beastless
wears shades of blue the procession is
flanked by banners one showing the
mythosar the Signet of this watch
overall and then on the left this symbol
of house be slow the bottom of that
Banner is that reverse F looking symbol
that's also on the decision worn by Boba
Fett the Sigil of Jester Muriel that was
Django's mentor and this white helmeted
one in the procession carries this same
flowered branch on a red cloth Paws
visla's son we think it's the sun Ragnar
is played by Wesley Kimmel nephew to
Jimmy Kimmel and he's the same kid from
some of the in-universe commercials in
Marvel's One Division pause these Liz of
course voiced by John Favreau but
underneath the armor he's played by
actor Tate Fletcher who played an
on-camera role in the pilot we do see
some other house banners on display a
green armored Mandalorian holding a red
and white Banner that might show the
animal Sigil of Clan Eldar so what we
are seeing here is a type of baptism
thus this boy submerged in water like in
Christian baptisms and all this is to
show us why din jar and bathing in the
Living Waters of Mandalore is such a
critical renewal this is the moment that
all mandalorians in the watch close
themselves off from the world the
armorer recites a pledge and the boy
repeats I swear on my name and the names
of the ancestors that I shall walk the
way of the mend allure in the words to
the Creed shall be forever forged in my
heart and the subtitles revealed the
armorer said the way capital W of the
manned Allure apostrophe in Middle there
which refers to the ruler of the
Mandalorian people also the Creed shall
be forever forged of course the concept
of foraging and armor coming back into
their words but when the armor replaces
the helmet over Ragnar's head it seals
and locks with this whistle sound effect
the same sound effect that the Darth
Vader mask made when it's sealed over
Anakin's face and Revenge of the Sith so
this in case scene isn't necessarily a
good thing it's really a human face
being entombed in metal but the ceremony
gets interrupted before the boy can
promise to never remove his helmet the
Beast or fate intervenes so is the watch
legitimately cursed or is it just their
strict ritual to Shield their faces and
wall themselves off from all other
connection that is actually cursed thank
you to betterhelp for sponsoring this
video movies and TV can be great
escapism but when it's time to face
things head on better help is here to
help better help is the world's largest
therapy service and it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 25 000 licensed and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues to get started just
answer a few questions about what you're
looking for from therapy and what your
preferences are better help will then
match you with a therapist from their
Network that's right for you after that
talk to your therapist however you feel
comfortable whether that's via text chat
phone or video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge better
help gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy so pause lays down the heavy
repeating Blaster fire While others fly
onto the Beast back to slap on the
charges and I love this shot where the
camera is mounted on the helmet Blaster
scar visible and notice on this one
shoulder plate the W shaped Death Watch
sigil this is based on the Hawk
unfortunately for them their
excommunicated apostate has to come bail
them out tin jarin in his modded in one
Naboo Starfighter that he got in the
book of Boba Fett and he fires what a
proton torpedo at the Beast the same
projectile that Luke fired at the Death
Star in the cave the armor repeats what
she told him on the Grievous ring world
as in I already told you once get
now in chapter 5 of The Book of Boba
Fett the armor explained how on the
night of a thousand tears the Empire
bombed the planet of Mandalore with
these Fusion bombs that apparently
turned the sand into this turquoise
glass like the sand of the real world's
Trinity Atomic testing site din shows
The Shard of this encasing a metallic
plate that contains an inscription in
the mandoa language now it's upside down
from the Armor's point of view if you
flip it on the fourth line you can make
out you out of the field which is part
of the King James Bible Old Testament
Exodus book 10 verses 5-6 and credit two
general Anubis on Reddit for being the
first to translate this bully and they
shall cover the face of the Earth and
one cannot be able to see the Earth and
they shall eat the residue of which is
escape which remaineth unto you from the
hail and eat every tree which groweth
for you out of the field and they shall
fill thy houses and the houses of all
thy servants and the houses of all the
Egyptians which neither thy fathers nor
thy fathers fathers have seen since the
day that they were upon the Earth unto
this day and he turned himself and went
out from Peril yeah it's been odd for
Star Wars to have real world Easter eggs
like this but you know they've also
referenced Indiana Jones on Andor and
E.T in the prequels this is referring to
the eighth plague of Egypt when Moses
had God sent Lucas upon the crops when
Pharaoh refused to free the Hebrews I
actually referenced The Prince of Egypt
in my deep dive live stream and this is
the part where it's like
the Lord awesome movie this parallels
the plagues of Mandalore a similarly
cursed people seeking relief from forces
trying to Smite their firstborn Sons
which actually might have inspired the
Beast crocodile Jaws like the crocodiles
of the Nile that the slave children were
thrown into by the Egyptians and the
croc-headed Amit being the Egyptian
Devourer of the dead but are the
mandalorians the Hebrews or the
Egyptians the slaves are the oppressors
sure they're diasporatic Wanderers like
the Hebrews were but they were forced
out of their ancestral lands due to some
believe their own Folly but we could see
Mando as Moses who leads the people
through the desert but never himself
makes it to the promised land that was
the job of Joshua his successor which
might be who grogu is though grogui is
kind of the bastard of the basket notice
grogu is wearing chainmail under his
robes this best guard chainmail was
given to grogu as a gift by din jarin in
chapter 6 of The Book of Boba Fett grogu
chose this instead of Yoda's lightsaber
while in hyperspace grogu gazes up to
see a Giant Shadow keeping Pace these
are the pergil a semi-sentient species
of hyperspace whales who first appeared
in Star Wars Rebels and carried off Ezra
Bridger and Grand Admiral thrawn into
hyperspace never to be seen again Rebels
ended with Ahsoka reunited with Sabine
Wren in search of Ezra and Amanda season
2 Ahsoka revealed she was still
searching for thrawn so this side in the
per girl here is a key indicator that we
are getting closer to Ezra I just love
the scale of it the immense size of the
pearls compared to the Starfighter but
something even deeper is going on with
grogu here the blue lights the whale
Shadows just makes it seem like we're
underwater so danger is aiming to
re-baptize himself this episode grogu is
going through his own aquatic style
baptism reaching out to these whales
bonding with them through the force we
didn't see in the Boba Fett finale that
with that Rancor he is able to connect
with creatures like this these whales
could be telling grogu where Ezra is how
does grogu respond no thanks he goes
down and Cuddles with his Mandalorian
Papa he doesn't want to follow a Jedi
path right now this is a way so they
return to Navarro and across the town
there's a lot more Greenery remember
Navarro has a volcanic surface and in
the overhead shot you can see the town
is on a lava field so the greenery is
similar to how after a volcano erupts in
the real world it enriches the soil and
allows dense forestation to form
compared to season one Navarro has
undergone a dramatic upgrade visible
even from this front gate which is no
longer crumbling Roku also has a new
bassinet with a headlamp light on the
side they pass some Nuna roasting over a
fire these are the common delicacy in
the Star Wars universe that you can
actually get at Galaxy's Edge they taste
like turkey because they are I guess
there's also a CEO series cook Joy like
the one we saw in the book of Boba Fett
and another upgrade from before when
kawaki monkey lizards were being roasted
by Jawas on a spit now wild kawakian
monkey lizards are populating the trees
and somehow moving without puppet hands
up their butts the protocol Droid tells
Mando yes since this is a volcanic area
they have geothermal Hot Springs great
cargo will later push these on din as
well another example of ninjar and being
lured By the Waters of other places on
his voyage to The Living Waters of
Mandalore this episode really is just a
journey to find the right bathtub we see
this band with a couple Twilights and a
grand race we pass a mon calamari
perched on the Statue of ig-11 is a
long-tailed bird thought that was
interesting but ig-11 is totally Captain
Morgan a Thompson Stormtrooper helmets
also interesting how some guy keeps a
small version of that reptilian bat that
attacked them in season one he's
domesticated it's a pet on his shoulder
you know like those cool guys walk
around with parrots but when grogu
Indian look up at the Statue I love that
they animated grogu's Shadows separately
to sell the fact that he's floating but
we also see the streets are now paved
with cobblestones which they were not
before greed karga is now the high
magistrate two droids straight Landing
vicarious Kate Park is finery and
jewelry is a bit much I'm worried about
this guy they use this fun horizontal
wipe edit matching it on the motion of
grogu force pushing spinning the chair
around just a nice bit of visual flow
there but it's also interesting how
Greek tells Dan he can hang up his
Blaster when later we realized he really
wants Mando to be his Marshal the head
of security so Greek is still being a
bit deceptive the guy keeps a golden
bust of himself in his office I mean
come on the pirate vein is inikto played
by Marty matulis a very physical
performer with a number of roles with
heavy Prosthetics including trigger
warning versus body Gore here actually
I'm gonna blur some of this out the
monstrosity from smile last year the
school with a protocol Droid teacher
looks like the same school where grogu
spent a day in season two when he snatch
those blue cookies and the tension
escalates yeah I love how on the word
soft Nando leans off the tree and you
can hear his heart hurt best car scrape
in the bark we get a classic Western
Gunslinger pose on Grief as he Reveals
His blaster on his hip just like the
shot of Han Solo when he stepped into
frame to face Jabba and the Spaceport in
A New Hope grief says Cara Dune has been
recruited by find Special Forces and
that mop Gideon is facing a new Republic
War tribunal which could be an allergy
to the Nuremberg trials that prosecuted
war crimes committed by the Nazis they
dismantle ig-11 statue to try to rebuild
him and we hear taikuy TT's voice return
as he defaults to his original
programming before Khalil reprogrammed
him to be a nurse yeah it 11 is actually
reverted to the last thing he said
before Mando shot him down to save grogu
in a pilot episode he crossed toward
them like Terminator to Sarah Connor and
I'd love to stop motioning movement it
just looks like the old school design
that always looked really cool in the
80s Star Wars films but definitely makes
him look real creepy too Mando tells
grief that he cannot handle ig-11 with
his limbs if things go scud scud being
an in-universe term Pali Moto and season
two referred to a skank and a scud pie
there's also the character of scud the
Disposable assassin Rob shrubs comic
about a malfunctioning robot assassin
and who does kind of look like an IG
Droid the azaleans are here they're all
voiced by Shirley Henderson who also
voiced Babu Frick in the rise of
Skywalker and this is the actress who
played money Myrtle so the enzymens are
renowned Droid repairman because their
eyes can spot super tiny details of the
wiring Commando sits in inside this tiny
Workshop looking like Gandalf and Bag
End and The Fellowship of the Ring yes
hoodoo is the atis word for bantha
fodder so our man does speak at tease
and grogu hugs zanzelin and I just love
one puppet hugging another puppet real
Miss Piggy and Kermit Vibes here and I
just love that they had to build one
merged puppet to pull this off the
Pirates return in the asteroid field and
grogu Tucks into din's bandolier strap
to stay snug during the chase the M1
legitimately disappears for a beat and
synced to Joseph Shirley's music in a
blast of lid vigurance's flute with each
of these hits Mando takes out each
pirate one by one but it was all a trap
to lure Mando into gory and Shard his
pirate ship looks like an old republic
thranta class Heavy Cruiser and the
concept art at the end of the episode we
see this pirate ship as its own badass
launch bay at the top of it pirate king
gory and Shard one of the most amazingly
designed Davey Jones I've
ever seen in Star Wars It's played by
nonzo a nosy Zara zawan doxos from Game
of Thrones 10 boosts out of there
piloting to calabala the home world of
house Crees mentioned a few times that
clone wars were never shown in live
action until now this rain-soaked Castle
strikes the sharp angles evoking
Dragonstone from Game of Thrones and it
forces Dan into yet another soaking the
wrong dousing of water on his path to
the right bathtub he even carries on
with Bo Katan in the next scene
completely soaked this great hall is
empty and it's covered in the banners of
the Night Owl sigil a boca tan what's
pretty sad considering it seems like
axwells and cascar Reeves abandoned her
when she didn't come back with a dark
saber kind of like she threw her own
birthday party and no one showed up
poketon lounges casually bored
despondents in her throne her leg
pointing toward this interesting carb
tab low of her warring ancestors at the
top of that Dogpile is one with a sword
really the only Mandalorian known with a
sword historically is tarvisla or
someone else from house Vizsla in its
family tree I wonder if this Tableau
shows the war of the craze household the
other side a tableau that would be to
bocaton's right might show another
Tableau that shows them finding peace
war on one side piece on the other like
the US presidential seal with the eagle
one side with the arrows represent War
one side with olive branch representing
peace and in this case bogoton's leg
would be angled to the war side we never
see the other side in the scene maybe
because bocaton is unable to see the
light now when these two first met in
season two on Trask the positions were
reversed it was Bo Katan who wanted to
go to Mandalore did John was the one who
believed it was cursed and poisoned that
planet is cursed anyone who goes there
dies but now it is bokotanu says but we
know there is some Mandalorian magic we
just don't know if the magic is a
blessing or curse are they the chosen
people or the doomed people we will find
out next week when din heads to the
ruins of sundari hey a reminder to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive and he can support us by grabbing
some merch at nerdright.shop you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow me rockstars And subscribe
to rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
thank you